Let's go next to our color from the three
one five area code.
Who's calling today from three one five, three
one five.
Uh, all of a sudden it's gone.
There you go.
Three one five is back.
That's you?
Yeah.
Hello? Yes.
Oh, okay.
Um, my name is Dan.
I'm from the Syracuse area.
Um, so it's kind of hard for me to word this
question.
Um, but I, I listened to you, I listened to
secular talk, Jimmy Dore.
You're probably aware of those too.
Yes.
But I'm going to be removing your mention
of Jimmy Dore When we upload this.
Just like a he did to Sam Cedar Cause I can't
have his name being mentioned on my [inaudible].
Yeah.
Okay.
I did see that.
I saw the videos.
So my question is basically there seems to
be, um, a difference in your guys' view of
the Mueller investigation.
And I guess they, they view it as more of
something that's counterproductive to the
progressive movement and they see it as like
a, as kind of like an establishment investigation
or like they've saved the deep state in which
wait a second.
[inaudible] secular talk is saying is talking
about the investigation is the deep state.
Uh, I believe he's mentioned the word deep
state, but I do know that he has many videos
on it and he is very critical of the investigation.
He, from the beginning, he said that there
was a bunch of bs.
Okay.
I want to be really careful.
So listen, I'm with peace and love.
I'm not going to assume you're accurately
characterizing that only because it's extremely
hard for me to imagine Kyle is talking about
the deep state as the source of the investigation.
So, so maybe you can ask me what I think about
it, but because I haven't heard what either
of these people have said about it, I would
not be able to respond to what you're saying.
They said.
All right.
So yeah, so let's say that he didn't say deep
state.
So basically, I guess my question is what
do you think of the idea that it's counter
to counterintuitive to the progressive movement
or that, for example, if it was a, if he did
the same thing with Saudi Arabia, there wouldn't
be an investigation and that, for example,
something he would say that the only reason
that the investigation started was because
Trump was threatening to pull out of Syria.
And you know, that that's,
so I think as far as the timing, I don't think
the timing, I don't think that that idea that
the investigation started because Trump was
threatening to pull out of Syria.
I don't think the timing of that makes sense.
Although I'd have to look at the dates.
Um, I guess I would say to you, in what way
has the investigation been counterproductive
for the progressive movement?
Well, I personally, I would think that, you
know, I think that trying to impeach Trump
on this issue, uh, is not the issue he should
be in,
on which issue.
Hold on.
Which issue?
Who's trying to, who's trying to impeach Trump
on which issue?
On the issue of him colluding with Russia
or the obstruction of justice issue.
Okay.
So on obstruction of justice, Mueller did
find that on a to 14 counts, Trump's actions
met all three legal requirements to be obstruction.
Do you agree or disagree with that part?
Like, do you agree that that's what Muller
said?
Um, I'm, I did, I did read the, that there
were, I thought there were 10 codes in which
I thought the wording was these could be,
these could be classified as obstruction of
justice.
That's right.
I think it would actually, I think it was
maybe even 14 that could be obstructive apps
and then on eight and then on eight, right.
Substantial evidence was found meeting all
three legal requirements on eight of the 14
or eight of the 10.
So you agree you're not disputing Mueller's
finding there?
No, I wouldn't dispute his findings.
I guess my position would be that I think
when it comes down to it, that the Russian
investigation, um, was something that I think
it's counterintuitive because I think that
there's actual things that Trump has done
that are more willing, more willing to have
him be impeached for, like, for example, what's
going on in Yemen.
And I think that it's kind of a distraction.
And I think the only reason that it's such
a big deal, especially with a lot of people
from the establishment is that it's Russia.
So for example, like my point was that, you
know, let's say that Hillary, um, had done
the same exact thing that Trump did, but with
Saudi Arabia,
no, I think that that's not the right path.
I listen, I'm 100% with you.
The Yemen's stuff is impeachable and I have
a video saying, aside from everything in the
Russia probe, Trump should be impeached for
the Yemen stuff.
So I'm completely with you there.
But when people start going into, if Trump
did this with Saudi Arabia or if Hillary did
that with Saudi Arabia, I mean, listen there,
there were the basis for this investigation
is now widely established.
Uh, and the investigation happened.
It's now done.
It's over.
We've got a report, we want to publicize the
content of the report and people can make
of it what they will.
Right.
So how about, would you agree then though,
that his actions with Yemen are more egregious
than with Russia and that it's not necessarily
a good thing that his things with Russia are
getting more attention from the media?
Uh, we are, are you talking about obstruction
or are you talking about collusion?
So, uh, I guess both of those, just everything
with Russia, like the whole Helsinki, the
whole trees and thing, just like the entire
treason.
But you're, so you're, you're all over the
place.
I don't even know that treason, treason, as
mentioned in the Mueller report.
So listen here, here's my view and I got a
run.
Um, I think the Yemen stuff is a disaster.
It's totally different than the obstruction
stuff.
They're both serious.
I think there are a number of bases on which
you should have impeachment inquiries.
And I think that that, that's basically, you
know, as far as I can get on it right now.
Okay.
Well thank you.
All right.
I appreciate your call.
Uh, man, just all over the place.
It's hard to, we gotta focus in, you know
what I mean?